it's been quite a while since i've done
a trolley problem memes video
and i thought it would be kind of cool
to get back to it and to focus on
some of the great memes that are out
there that tie
in directly with philosophy
so there's there's quite a few out there
i picked the top ten
we should remind ourselves what the
trolley problem is
there's two main formulations that you
can see
actually there's lots and lots of other
formulations but the first one
has a trolley and
a divergence in a track as you can see
here
if you let the trolley keep going on its
normal path it's going to crush and kill
five people and if you flip the switch
then one person will die in place of
five
another variation on this is to have a
fat man that you push
off of the bridge who will actually stop
the trolley
so once again sacrificing one person
to save five and the idea is
that how you approach this problem
shows whether you're more deontological
or more utilitarian
and there is no proper solution to the
thing
as a matter of fact there's an
anti-solution which many people have
proposed
called called multi-track drifting but
we won't talk about that
here so let's take a look at the memes
here's the first one i like this one
you're a podgy utilitarian you do not
yet have the sufficient mass to stop a
trolley but
with your current dietary habits you're
slowly getting there
every day on your way to work you have
to walk across a railway overpass
is it your obligation to eat enough to
obtain trolley stopping weight in case a
trolley problem one day
occurs and now you know a utilitarian of
course would say
no because there's other factors
involved but this is this is a great way
to
approach the problem and to think about
it in
utilitarian fashion so that's kind of a
funny one
the next one you know playing off of
albert camus you see
that that's his face right there saying
there's only one serious
philosophical trolley problem of course
that's a reference
to his his beginning of the myth of
sisyphus where he says that there's one
serious philosophical problem and that
is of
suicide of course he's going to change
that later on
and the rebel to murder as well
but you know you notice that it's a
question of whether
he flips the switch or doesn't and if he
doesn't
suppose i guess it runs over him
the next one has got two different
philosophers
and these are two social contract
theorists that we
often oppose to each other when we're
teaching them in intro to philosophy
classes or in textbooks
so the state of nature according to
hobbs or lock in hobbs
the trolley will continue towards b that
is on the path which isn't going to hurt
anybody
unless you were the stranger redirected
towards the other one well you hope the
stranger
doesn't pull the lever or will you do it
before he does presumably whoever pulls
the lever first gets it to go
towards the other person and hobbes is
of course very famous for having said
that in the state of nature we can't
trust each other
life is uh nasty brutish and short
and there's causes for human conflict
which which
even stem far from our own rationality
the lockheed trolley problem instead in
the state of nature were actually quite
good to each other
the lot the trolley will continue
towards b everything's fine
there's no flips or levers to flip
or anything like that uh it's a bit of a
misrepresentation i would say
since the state of nature is a little
bit more complicated than that but it's
a good meme
nonetheless here's one that's even
funnier
so you know who that is right that's ein
rand
and she's got the trolley and she's
definitely going to flip the switch
to protect one's beloved husband now of
course she doesn't doesn't have one but
a lover it could be right versus a
thousand strangers this is coming from
her discussion
in the um the virtue of selfishness
when she talks about how how it is that
you could sacrifice yourself
or sacrifice other things for a beloved
person
and in this case you'd sacrifice any
unlimited number of people who you
really don't care much about
the next one this is a really good one i
may actually use this in class the veil
of ignorance
the trolley problem so veil of ignorance
is coming from
john rawls a theory of justice and the
idea is that when we're like
reconstituting a society
as essentially as a thought experiment
we do so behind a veil of ignorance we
have no
idea where we're going to end up in the
society so the idea is that we'd make
the society a bit more
equitable a bit more just we'd limit
people's exposure to
you know things that make them
vulnerable for irrational reasons so in
this case you don't know where you're
going to be
in the trolley problem but you have to
choose the scenario
in advance but of course the only the
only choice that they give you here is
do you want the lever
to be pulled and i think the rational
thing to do
in that case would be in fact to pull
the lever
although you could say well you don't
know whether you're going to be
more utilitarian or made more
deontological with this so
maybe maybe there's no solution
actually possible in in this
case not quite quite sure
now we get into the versions of the
trolley
problem where bringing philosophers in
is
actually turning it into a different
kind of
kind of problem or issue and so we've
got
zeno here right this is of course zeno
of aleah
and the trolley problem is in this case
turned into the fact that you could
never actually crush anybody
because if you remember your your basic
you know pre-socratic philosophy xeno
had said well you gotta cross the
halfway point
and then you gotta get to the halfway
point between that and the object and
then halfway point of that and halfway
so you never
actually complete completed these were
arguments that zeno was giving to
support his uh
his uh teacher permanity's contention
that that
change in motion was impossible so
that's really kind of a different
trolley problem
and we can say something similar as well
with this interesting variation
as well the chinese room trolley problem
of course coming from john searle's
chinese room
issues a man who does not understand
philosophy is enclosed within a room
he's continually fed trolley problems on
slips of paper
he answers them all according to a fixed
set of instructions inside the room
he manages to convince some of the
people outside the room he's really a
philosopher
however does he really understand
philosophy
so this is analogous to a problem about
you know artificial intelligence and
whether whether
a computer could be said to really
understand
um and notice that what it picks in the
end
its output is always multi-track
drifting which is let's kill
everybody so that's kind of an
interesting one
here is the the last of these
problems the ship of theseus trolley
problem
this is changing things considerably if
you do not pull the lever one person
will be crushed to death instantly
if you do pull the lever the trolley
will divert onto a thousand mile stretch
of track with one person tied down at
the end of it so somebody's getting
killed no matter what
if as the trolley rolls down this
thousand mile track a crew
systematically switches out every piece
of the original trolley
with a replacement part did the trolley
which you diverted
kill the man so this is changed from a
moral problem
into a question about the identity
the metaphysical identity of the trolley
and
you know again very different kind of
problem here isn't it
here's another where the trolley problem
is being you could say
reimagined in a somewhat different way
so this is the arthur
schopenhauer trolley problem
schopenhauer of course
was you know pretty pessimistic about
life so let's just see what this one
says
according to schopenhauer's
anti-natalist view the sum of all human
experience
is overwhelmingly negative therefore
pulling the lever would only take one
person out of this dreaded existence and
cause the
five to continue living with horrible
pain associated with life
assuming this pessimistic philosophical
view with the utilitarian thing be
for the first time to not pull the lever
so the utilitarian thing mixing
utilitarianism and schopenhauer together
of course
which are not exactly the same and
schopenhauer by the way doesn't think
that everybody's aware
of how crappy life is so what you've
really got are a whole bunch of
schopenhauerns
tied to the tracks people who've had the
sort of
vision or insight that that he has
and it reminds me of the old joke about
masochists and sadists right the
masochist is the one who says hurt me
hurt me and the sadist is the one who
says no i won't
so this is kind of a funny one
now i saved a a final one this is
actually
coming from a cartoon and this is really
quite great
you notice you've got phyllis philosophy
convention sightseeing to her
and the guys saying everyone the trolley
is out of control you have three seconds
to bail out before we're going too fast
and it says by the time we realized it
wasn't a thought experiment it was too
late
which probably would be the case with
philosophers so
this is a a set of uh new trolley memes
well not really new
uh just new in this video some of these
have been floating around for quite a
while but i thought you might get a kick
out of them at least as much
as i have so i'll i may do more of these
in the future if i find some other
interesting
trolley memes to take a look at that i
haven't put into
this or the previous two trolley meme
videos but
for the for the time being that's all
folks
you